if you can limit your interaction with
your loved ones who are negative and
pessimistic you can't cut your mom out
you can't cut your brother out can you
limit your mom and brother you can if
your mom's extremely negative and you're
watching us right now and you realize
that you are pessimistic and this is
what's actually holding you down and you
say you know what I'm not going to talk
to my mom four times a day because I
watch this you know who listens to
people that complain other people that
want to complain to that person it's
just one big complaining Circle
if you can limit mom if she's the one to
once every four days instead of four
times a day and add Sally from The
Office who's a bundle of joy you would
not believe what would happen if you
watch one hour less of the news or in
your screen except like what's wrong in
the world and you spend one hour more of
what's good in the world one hour a day
that will change everyone's life